Sure. So, the OHDSI tools were really designed to bring together the set
of most common tool kits that people would use for doing observational clinical research.
So, if you wanted to ask a question of a health data set,
what OHDSI has done is brought together in one package,
which we call ATLAS, a set of tools to understand your population,
to understand individual cohorts within that population,
and to be able to explore those pre-clinical research questions.
It's actually a nice compliment between FHIR and in OHDSI.
In that, FHIR typically is that the individual patient level pulling data down.
Where OHDSI really typically looks things at a population level or at a cohort level.
So, they're very complementary in fact.
Sure, absolutely.
So, indeed ATLAS does roll together all of
these different components that are part of doing observational research.
So, as you can see here,
there's an initial piece which is around data set exploration.
And if you look here,
and you click through to the individual dataset explorer,
you can pick a dataset of interest,
you can look graphically at the populations,
you can look at how many people are taking different medications,
how many people have different conditions on their list.
So, that's a key part of understanding,
"What do I have to begin with?
What does my population look like?"
But if I want to go to the next level and build a particular cohort,
which you would do if you were going to ask a question.
For example, how many patients over 50 with diabetes are taking Metformin.
Well, if you want to define,
"What do I mean by patients with diabetes?"
And to do that, we use the cohort builder tool over here.
And by clicking through the cohort builder,
you have an option you can see to graphically create and select a series of
different conditions that are relevant to diabetes.
You can select medications that are relevant to diabetes and laboratories,
and those are all defined in this way here.
You pick a concept set.
That concept set is then created by a vocabulary explorer.
The vocabulary explorer says, "Let me look at
Metformin medications or other diabetes drugs.
Let me look at ICD 9 codes that mean diabetes and then go up to the parent level,
that can include SNOMED concepts,
ICD 10 concepts, and so forth."
And you roll those into concept sets.
So, the way that this vocabulary explorer complements
the cohort builder is to allow you to create your little bundles of,
when I say diabetes here's what I mean in terms of codes.
By doing this, we can then run these population level estimation analysis,
which is that final piece of ATLAS, where you can say,
"I want people who have diabetes and have taken metformin and I want
people who have diabetes and have taken other medications such as sulfonylureas,
and I can look at the outcomes."
And that can be looking at, for example, myocardial infarction.
So by creating these three cohorts are what we call a treatment cohort,
what we call a comparator cohort,
and our outcome cohort,
we can then automatically run through
the ATLAS tool a very sophisticated analysis which is rigorous and
actually publishable almost directly from the code that's run
in the ATLAS tool.
Exactly. And so one of
the major initiatives that we're taking on this year here at Georgia Tech,
in collaboration with our colleagues at Stanford
is building a formalized Fino type library.
Where people can review what were
the conditions that were considered in designing a given phenotype.
What was the performance in terms of the precision and recall of a given cohort.
And provide additional information,
so that if someone wants to reuse this cohort in their own environment,
what they can expect in terms of its performance.
We also encourage people who do run studies to upload their own findings.
As far as how well did this definition do in my local system,
and it then allows us to produce better and better cohorts to share with the rest
of the OHDSI community.
It's a really exciting time.
I think for OHDSI as a community that has
now grown well beyond its roots looking just at drug safety,
into where with people considering studies around genomics and around value based care,
certainly looking at population health at large.
We've even had a number of people say,
"We want to look at clinical trials themselves using OHDSI,
" which is interesting given
the original ideas around observational research and clinical trials being separate.
The other big piece though, is with FHIR,
we're now seeing a easier pathway to go from EMR data of all stripes,
and from all different systems into an OHMOP common data model.
That GT on FHIR or OHMOP on FHIR project done here at Georgia Tech,
allows people to very rapidly implement a conversion from
FHIR into OHMOP and take advantage of all the tools that OHMOP has.
At the same time, if someone builds
a predictive model using advanced machine learning methods,
many of which have been developed here at Georgia Tech,
or extensively refined here at Georgia Tech,
those predictive models can then be run through
an EMR system to actually do a prediction for individual patient.
So, the connection between clinical decision support and
large scale analytics has really been
enabled by this combination of FHIR and OHDSI together.
So, it's a great time to be working on this,
and I think it's only going to grow in the years ahead.
Thanks very.